قام توماس كوفيل بتجديد هذه الآلة
التجديف أو مخابرات الإنترنت كانت كذلك
ابن في مسار ماجني حيث نحن
رحب في العناوين
صدر سيكون أكثر في وسائلهم إيلان أماه
المعركة سوف يكون لها حماسة من قضبان
قوائم ماري linyekula لا شيء ياهو بليك
روبنز حيث لديها ليل حيث mathieu
dandenault ضروري لأن ذلك
يسمح بتعقب الأطفال ومن ثم
أمي أيضا للإجابة على الأسئلة و
لمرافقة ذلك
أكثر اطمئنانًا في هذه الفترة
القلق الناجم خلال الجامو ليس وحده و
كيف تخبر المرأة أن كل شيء على ما يرام
إذا أخذنا العجين كن حذرا إذا استمعنا
لا يسقط b6 هو دائما له
لدينا الكثير من الأسئلة
طلبات حاليا من جبان
الذين يريدون الولادة في المنزل
لماذا يوجد في المنزل
لا الهالة التي تأتي لفعل الكثير
في منزلها ثم أنا شخصيا
أعتقد أنه محفوف بالمخاطر بعض الشيء
لست للولادة
مسكن
لن أفعل ذلك لكننا نحاول
أطمئن كما يمكننا أمي والسكان المحليين
للولاية مثل ولاية نارنيا
كارولين فيما يتعلق بالتجمعات حيث
رقص البلد تصويره verbard من أنا إلى
فتاة موروني كلارا ليه مولهوسين
رميها
الطفل يتأثرون لأننا
نحن لا نعرف شيئا عن هذا الفيروس ونحن كذلك
ليس آمنًا أن لدينا أعراض و
أنه تم نقله إلى الطفل ماذا
ارتكب الخطأ